[Musica]
faccio lettere musicologo ma in realtà
ho iniziato che avevo 42 anni a studiare
queste cose prima facevo semplicemente
il cantore a tenore cantavo al mio paese
con gli amici da quando ero ragazzino ho
imparato intorno ai 14 anni non mi ero
mai posto troppi problemi del perché del
percome si cantasse a tenore di tutte le
tradizioni della sardegna del paese
stesso
andavo così con braccio con gli amici è
continuato per tanti anni finché poi al
conservatorio è arrivata questa
opportunità di un corso di
etnomusicologia e lì mi sono iscritto
frequentato il corso dopo tre anni di
una laurea breve un corso di laurea
breve o finito per diventare così tra
virgolette titolato etnomusicologo in
realtà non vuol dire niente
però ho capito tante delle dinamiche
riguardanti la musica di tradizione
orale è un po così mi ci sono veramente
dedicato dopo a studiare in particolare
il canto a tenore il canto a tenore
della sardegna del quale proprio oggi
voglio parlarti di cosa si tratta
si tratta di una forma di canto
polivocale in cui 4 cantori generalmente
degli uomini ragazzi uomini più o meno
adulti cantano dei versi di poesie della
tradizione della sardegna
questo canto diciamo che può essere
considerato come un modo per fare musica
io lo vedo un po simile al rock al blues
in una versione ovviamente sarda come
funziona funziona che c'è un solista che
intona dei versi e altri tre che cantori
che lo accompagnano e mettendo dei versi
ovvero pronunciando delle sillabe
nonsense non dicono le parole
solo un cantore chiamato szabo che canta
il testo ferma le di questa esibizione
canora
cosa accade che il cantore non ha una
melodia da seguire non esiste come
normalmente si è abituati nella musica
una linea melodica una parte
prestabilita del cantare è proprio un
modo di inventarmi musica ecco perché
diceva che un po somiglia al blues
in pratica a un come una sorta di
canovaccio una tela grezza a maglie
larghe che è fatta dai canoni della
tradizione all'interno di questo egli
può scegliere il testo e può scegliere
le melodie che personalmente gli
riescono meglio che meglio comunicano e
le sue sensazioni del momento
oppure che meglio si associano al testo
verbale che egli sta cantando è una cosa
che è molto legata al mondo della poesia
improvvisata e della poesia in genere in
quanto il canto a tenore storicamente ma
anche attualmente può essere considerato
come uno strumento al servizio della
poesia tutti i cantori che fanno sabot
che cioè questo solista che intona il
canto sono delle persone
appassionatissime di poesia e conoscono
a memoria
centinaia diversi o di interi testi
poetici della tradizione orale e anche
della tradizione scritta della sardegna
e quindi sono in grado volta per volta
di scegliere il testo da cantare e gli
altri cantori ivan dietro facendo loro
la musica l'accompagnamento infatti la
terminologia dice cantare a tenore a
cantare solamente il solista gli altri
magnano in quello che viene chiamato
superiore ovvero il coro di
accompagnamento e difficile
l'ho verificato poi insegnando al
conservatorio e difficile per chi è
abituato alla musica classica o diciamo
agli standard musicale attuali imparare
da adulto a cantare a tenore perché
tutti quanti noi
in pratica abbiamo bisogno quasi di una
guida musicale non dico della musica
scritta ma almeno di una melodia da
seguire da ripetere quindi quando si
prova a imparare a cantare tenore quando
si è invece abituati a fare altra musica
è veramente complicato liberarsi da
questi blocchi e poter cantare
liberamente mentre i ragazzi che
apprendono il canto a tenore nelle
tradizioni dei vari paesi lo fanno in
modo naturale perché acquisiscono prima
tutta la cultura del canto le modalità
con il con le quali il canto può
esprimersi e solo dopo loro provano a
interpretarlo
all'inizio imitano i cantori più anziani
prendono da loro sia le parole delle
loro dei loro canti sia alcune tratti
melodici ma poi piano piano assumono un
allora una loro personalità nel canto
che diventa proprio una forma personale
di espressione poetico musicale
quindi ripeto il canto a tenore la
particolarità è che non ha un testo è
una musica precostituiti ogni volta il
cantore il solista salone sceglie il
testo da cantare e con quale tipo di
tanto vuole interpretare quel
determinato testo può accadere quindi
che un medesimo testo lo si possa
ascoltare cantato ambo gaballo oppure lo
si possa ascoltare cantato come si dice
amore notte il medesimo testo politico
cantato in duetto talmente diversi
altrettanto può accadere che il canto
beauvais ballo durante il canto il
cantore decida di cambiare testo anche
durante il canto oppure da un'esecuzione
all'altra cambia completamente quindi
ripete tutto il sistema musicale del
savoy e ballo però il testo è
completamente modificato quindi
l'associazione viene fatta nel momento
della performance non è una cosa
preconfezionata precostituita ma è
decisa tutta sul momento quindi fa parte
di quello che si può dire una parte di
improvvisazione musicale
c'è molta libertà interpretativa nel
canto a tenore che può apparire
esternamente abbastanza piatto in realtà
è di una dinamicità enorme perché gli
altri cantori che devono seguire il
solista sono tenuti a comprendere anche
tutte le sue tutto ciò che gli viene in
testa cioè passa per la mente e quindi
continua a cambiare stili modalità cambi
di tonalità e gli si deve star dietro
quindi c'è un ascolto e un cantare
veramente insieme costruire musica tutti
tutti insieme il tenore è fatto di
quattro parti queste quattro parti sono
su basso la parte più grave salon tra
una parte intermedia dal punto di vista
delle altezze savoia che quello che
abbiamo detto il solista esame smog e
che invece canta sul registro più acuto
quindi dal grave al culto queste sono le
quattro parti del tenore la
particolarità del tenore quale è che in
pratica queste quattro parti se vengono
emesse con tecniche vocali tutte una
diversa dall'altra
e questa la vera strada
proprio la forza del canto a tenore sta
in questo che nella tradizione sarda la
sardegna ha elaborato un modo di far
musica attraverso la voce facendo
diventare la voce stessa uno strumento e
quindi su basso
ve lo faccio sentire
[Musica]
[Risate]
o no
o
a queste su basso di un ragazzo di
siniscola un paese della provincia di
nuoro
sentiamo la contra
ma
bomba
e alla fine
ascoltiamo sarà attinente al sunred ma
light a kimi ma che scola
evita brutta
[Musica]
quindi si comprende che si tratta di
mettere insieme delle cose abbastanza
diverse proprio anche musicalmente però
è proprio dall insieme di questo che
nasce un suono del tutto particolare e
originale e unico al mondo proprio
perché mette insieme queste vocalità
così diverse è che come dire che in cui
sono sedimentate davvero tanti secoli
sono sedimentati in questo modo di far
musica
altra particolarità del canto a tenore è
che non c'è un unico modo di cantare in
sardegna è che il canto a tenore è
associato alla comunità alla quale
appartengono i cantori ovvero se io sono
per esempio di torpè e io canto con i
miei amici di thorpe specialmente nelle
situazioni pubbliche non è proprio
possibile che io canti con altri cantori
di altri paesi per due ordini di motivi
uno perché so cantare
ovviamente come si canta il mio paese lo
ha preso dal ragazzo eccetera ma anche
se imparassi le tecniche o gli stilemi
del paese accanto per così dire dal
punto di vista proprio del perché e del
come si fa tenore si canta tenore io
sono tenuto per tradizione e per cultura
del canto a cantare i canti del mio
paese così come gli altri cantano i
campi del loro paese quindi sentirete
sempre quando si parla di cantoria
tenore a fianco al nome del gruppo c'è
sempre il nome del paese di provenienza
del gruppo e questo non è un fatto
casuale non è perché ci tengano per
altri motivi e perché quei tanti
appartengono esattamente alla tradizione
di quella singola comunità
vi faccio sentire un esempio di un canto
a bocca notte che ho registrato in una
festa in campagna con mesto mesto dei
contesti abbastanza comuni
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no
[Musica]
si no
trasforma
[Musica]
da allora
delle questi che ama tanto amore notte
ovvero canto notturno si cantano dei
versi endecasillabi della tradizione
orale o delle poesie scritte da poeti
locali o da poeti sardi conosciuti in
questo caso erano dei ragazzi di orune
che interpretavano questo canto di una
festa campestre si sentiva il vento dal
microfono entrare dal microfono i canti
che si possono fare sono tre tipi di
tanti non dei canti veri e propri dette
le modalità di canto che sono nove notte
come vi ho appena detto canto notturno
molto usato nelle serenate boga ballo il
canto per l'accompagnamento dei balli e
muto il canto che accompagna invece all
improvvisazione dei versi chiamati mutuo
oppure il canto comunque diversi
conosciuti dei mutui che sono una forma
di poesia tipicamente sarda delle quale
ci vorrebbe un'altra di queste di questi
incontri per concludere il canto a
tenore è visto spesso come una cosa del
passato che viene come dire riproposta
oggi informa folk l'orizzonte di questo
certo il canto a tenore ha radici
profonde nel passato della sardegna e
viene dalla tradizione orale
però è un canto assolutamente moderno da
un'indagine fatta dall'associazione dei
tenores di cui faccio parte e si scopre
che il mestiere che svolgono diciamo
quasi il 50 per cento dei cantori attivi
oggi è quello di studente neanche un
mestiere
il che vuol dire che è un canto di
giovani come tutta la musica del resto
le persone che fanno musica non
professionalmente ma quelle che fanno
musica per il gusto di fare musica nella
società
sono quasi sempre dei giovani
spessissimo i giovani sono appassionati
di musica e il canto a tenore ha una
prevalenza di cantori assolutamente
giovani e anche quelli che non sono più
studenti che lavorano eccetera
fanno tutti diversi lavori che si fanno
in sardegna non è come in passato un
canto dei pastori certo il canto dei
pastori perché nel centro sardegna tutti
facevano i pastori oggi si fanno tutti i
mestieri abbiamo cantori che sono medici
insegnanti professionisti anche pastori
o qualunque altro al mestiere di
artigiani eccetera e si tratta di un
qualcosa che è talmente vivo vi faccio
un esempio recentissimo per me passa dal
mio paese dentro il centro storico li
attraversato il centro storico ea un
certo punto vedo uno strepitio di
ragazzini che corrono
poi si fermano in un angolo aspettavano
che io passassi perché volevano che io
uno dei cantori anziani della comunità
li potesse ascoltare erano ragazzini
della scuola media bambini si sono messi
in un angolo e cantavano e subito
guardavano chi starà guardando che
quindi oberti mi sono avvicinato per
dire quanto questa musica sia viva e i
ragazzi lo facciano con lo stesso
spirito di qualunque altra musica
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]